[Music]
I'm Richard prong I'm the William
Robertson Co professor of Ornithology at
Yale University and I'm the author of
the evolution of beauty so one of the
things that's really mysterious about
people is the evolution of our cognitive
complexity our long childhoods language
material culture all of these things and
they take large amounts of investment in
babies to get them to grow for a really
long time
this pattern of investment was only made
possible by overcoming male violence in
our primate ancestors male chimpanzees
and gorillas routinely murder babies for
their own sexual advantage when they
take over the troop and this kind of
infanticide is really damaging to the
sexual interests of the females so one
of the things that had to happen in
human evolution was to solve the
infanticide problem human females have
evolved or have used mate choice to
transform maleness in a way that
furthers their own sexual autonomy and
this could have included preferring
males that were smaller in relative body
size that is not as large as say
gorillas that had smaller canine teeth
they didn't have weapons in their faces
like our chimpanzee ancestors so this is
a kind of special way in which mate
choice can remodel maleness in a way
that furthers the sexual autonomy of the
female
[Music]